[Music]
we have watched descendants two loads of
times but we still can't get enough when
we talked about fan fiction before our
viewers were kind enough to tell us some
more descendants two fanfic that we
absolutely love
keep watching to the end when we'll meet
an awesome new character the daughter of
the Queen of Hearts from Alice in
Wonderland if this is your first time
visiting the things then do as a favor
hit the subscribe button and give this
video a thumbs up today we're going to
show you ten descendants two fan fiction
stories that are better than the
original part two there are so many ways
to celebrate our love something that fan
fiction does and does really well is to
take characters and move them a bit
further forward than when we saw them
it's also something that can take us
into an alternative universe and show us
how things could have been if they had
happened differently and that is why we
like this next work of fanfiction it's
called there are so many ways to
celebrate our love and it features mal
and then when you're on from when they
started dating it's written by luminous
Asuma what is very interesting about it
is that it might just take place in a
world without descendants - although
having said that it could equally take
place before descendants - or just as
likely a little bit after what happens
is that the happy couple are celebrating
their first anniversary which means that
they have to make a reservation at our
town's most expensive upmarket and
luxurious restaurant the enchanted
Lagoon of course with mouth' background
the idea of going there makes her rather
nervous and what makes things even worse
is that Ben is going to be late he says
he has to do what he calls a kingly work
thing before he can get there so mal
turns up on her own and she feels rather
anxious luckily Ben does show up and
everything works out how to be a perfect
princess we absolutely loved descendants
- but if we had to find one thing in it
that we maybe didn't like so much it's
that one of our favorite characters from
the first film didn't appear and that
character was Audrey if you aren't
entirely sure as to who she is a will
remind you she's the daughter of Aurora
and Prince Philip from Sleeping Beauty
she is a bit of a stereotypical
Christian
and she doesn't really trust now in a
way we can understand why that is
because at the start she's dating Ben
but then he leaves her from out but in
the end everything works out and Malin
Audrey join forces
like we said she isn't in descendants
too but she is mentioned first it's
revealed that she has gone on a spa
weekend with flora fauna and
Merryweather and then she calls Chad
charming and tells her that she is
stranded in Sherwood Forest but we were
including a story by flat fox about
Audrey it's called how to be a perfect
princess
it isn't very long but it packs a
serious emotional punch it's a little
look at Audrey and how she felt when BAM
left her for now we think you should
check it out because it's really good we
also hope that we see Audrey again in
the upcoming third descendants film
tough love one thing we really like
about both descendants and descendant 2
is that both movies have a very large
cast of characters of course this means
that in the movies we may not be able to
spend as much time with some of the more
minor characters as we might like to one
of our favorite characters who isn't a
big star is tad Charming he is the son
of Cinderella and Prince Charming to be
honest he isn't the nicest person in our
dumb prep but he is a low-key kind of
annoying
rather than actively evil and he does
have a fairly decent side to him -
because he descendants to me rushes off
to help his girlfriend Audrey even
though she has stuck 6 hours drive from
him anyway today we are going to tell
you about a story about Charming it's
called tough love and it's by strained
interest 32 in it were to cut back to
Chad's mother Cinderella about how her
son has been acting a tart on prep the
fairy godmother tells her that frankly
chad is been acting less like a hero and
more like a villain of course this sort
of thing can't really be allowed to
happen so she goes to visit Chad and his
schoolmates to see what is going on we
are going to tell you anything more but
if you want to find out what happens
then read it welcome to our Adan hide
something that descendants two did with
something that every good sequel should
do it introduced some interesting cool
and memorable new characters one of the
biggest new members of the cast was Emma
who is the main villain in the movie she
is the daughter of Ursula from The
Little
mermaid and she is someone who you don't
want to get on the wrong side of she has
portrayed absolutely perfectly by China
and McClain who gives the character
enough charisma to be interesting let's
put it this way
although she is the main villain in
descendants - that doesn't mean we don't
like her she's something we want to know
more about and although she does get her
comeuppance right at the end of the film
we are really hoping that she makes a
comeback in the upcoming descendants 3
anyway we found some cool stories about
her and we are going to tell you about
one called welcome to our Adan hi it's
written by heroes champ and it starts
with the premise that Ouma surrendered
at the end of the sentence - and Ben
ended up inviting her to auradon what we
like about it is that it gives us
another side of luma and it shows how
she might try to settle down and try to
start a new kind of life of course it
isn't always that simple but if you want
to know how she copes then read welcome
to Aragon hi Disney descendants fan
fiction works
one of the biggest motivations behind
fan fiction is the idea that you can
take some characters from a movie book
or TV show and then really go in depth
from their relationships in descendants
- perhaps the biggest pairing of
characters that people wanted to know
more about how they interacted together
was out of Harry Hook and uma Carey Luke
is the son of James Huck's better known
as Captain Hook from Peter Pan
he is unpredictable sneaky and I was on
the lookout to cook someone there is
something that makes him a little bit
sad though and that is that he has to
carry his hook in his pants he really
wishes he can have a hook instead of a
ham just like its father anyway when we
meet him in descendants - he is hanging
out with uma in his cart of her pirate
gang we think that he is pretty much her
second-in-command anyway one descendants
- fam took things to a new level with
their bit of fan fiction this rider is
called watermelon cat and their work is
called Disney descendants fan fiction
works it's a collection of short stories
all focused on the relationship between
harry and uma we like them and we have
to admire the way in which this writer
has gone in deep on these two characters
exploring what works with them
frustrating love when we put up our
original 10 descendants - fan fiction
stories that are better than the
original one thing we weren't expecting
was the sort of response we would end up
having from you our viewers we were
amazed and delighted by how many people
commented on our video telling us the
descendants - fan fiction stories that
they had written themselves we would
have talked to you about some of the
excellent stories that you guys told us
one of them is written by someone called
dar Keanu plays mcpe
if you're watching this we'd like to say
hello and thank you for your excellent
story
it's called frustrating love and we are
going to tell you a little bit about it
it introduces a new character who is
called I see Anna she is the daughter of
Jack Frost and Elsa from frozen
however she causes a bit of a problem
because Ben falls for in a big way you
could say that he falls for her hook
line & sinker
talking of hooks Harry hook is there to
comfort mal once Ben ditches her for the
new character something we've noticed in
general is how popular Harry hook is we
wonder if there'll be a bigger part for
him into sending three cool girls 16:28
story looking through some of the
stories that you left us in the comments
section of our 10 descendants tube fan
fiction stories that are better than the
original video one of the things we
loved was when you gave us new
characters that's really great because
adding new characters is one of the
things that fan fiction is for one of
the characters we really liked was in a
story by one of our viewers called cool
girl 1628 cool barrel 1628 if you are
watching this thank you for telling us
your story we aren't sure if it's got a
title but if you can think of one let us
know in the comments anyway this story
introduces us to a character called Gaby
Gaby is the daughter of mother Gothel
who you might remember from tangled
Disney's adaptation of the Rapunzel
fairy story
she was the evil witch who kidnapped
Rapunzel and kept her in a tower anyway
in cool-girl 1628 story we learned that
Gaby was actually abandoned by Mother
Gothel when she was just five years old
she moved to the Isle of the Lost where
she initially became friends with mal
and her gang only to become disappointed
when they moved to our Don however she
then met uma and her gang of pirates who
helped her to plot her revenge one of
the things we liked about this is how
its left open-ended we hope there's a
sequel descendants like a bolt out of
the blue when we put a video up we
absolutely love it when you leave your
comments when we posted our 10
descendants to fan fiction stories that
are better than the original something
that we loved was when people
recommended some of their favorite
descendants to fan fiction stories we
loved that what are the ones that caught
our eye was descendants like a bolt out
of the blue which was recommended to us
by Kashi Kim hi Kashi Kim thank you for
telling us about this story we hope that
you're a subscriber
anyway this story is absolutely
brilliant
written by Ava Hart it is an absolutely
epic life story and it is well worth the
time that it will take to Rita in it we
meet a brand new character called Kaylee
she has the adopted daughter of Ben yes
it's a story that takes the premise of
descendants - and moves it forward in
time that's a really great idea
so we've Kaylee and some of the other
characters - we are getting to meet the
descendants of the descendants if that
makes sense
well it should do because this is a
story that has its own continuity and
draws you into a part of the world of
descendants - that maybe I haven't spent
that much time with so if you want to
know more go and read descendants like a
bolt out of the blue
Ben's dilemma you might not realize it
but when you watch some of our videos
you're doing something that people all
across the world are doing we value all
our viewers and we love it when they
leave comments when we did our original
10 descendants - fan fiction stories
that are better than the original video
one of the stories we liked was from a
viewer called Christina McLean who is a
Romanian fan of descendants - buna
Christina multum asked for a tumult
Christina story is a really good and it
takes in so many of our favorite
characters from The Descendants
franchise it starts off with been asking
mouth--i Miriam of course with Mal
family background of villainy there are
plenty of people in auradon who are not
exactly delighted with the idea of now
ending up being their queen so mal finds
herself experiencing a bit of a problem
does she return to the Isle of the laws
to look after her fellow villain
descendants or does she do her duty and
rule as our dons Queen there is also a
dilemma for Bank does he listen to what
some of his subjects one and let mal go
or does he follow his heart and marry
now it's a really good story and we are
incredibly grateful that Christina
decided to share it with us not that
evil one of the many things that we like
doing when it comes to the whole
descendants franchise is trying to work
out who else should come along and join
our regular characters after all such
massive fan favorites as uma and Harry
hook were new characters and descendants
too so we wonder who else will join them
one character that appeared in one fan
fiction was one of our favorites and we
wondered if there'll be someone like
that in the next film it's by the fire
whisperer 13 and it is called not that
evil the author very kindly told us
about this on our earlier video and we
thank them for it it's about the
daughter of the Queen of Hearts from
Alice in Wonderland who is called Kyra
and how she gets the chance to study a
tart on prep but when she is there she
gets to meet Alice's daughter who
everyone thinks
a bit too crazy and gets bullies to find
out what happens you'll have to read it
but we think you should give it a go
because it's a very good story but we
wondered what new characters would you
like to see in descendants three and are
there any other fan fiction stories that
we've missed out
maybe you've written one so don't be shy
and let us know by leaving your comments
that's it for our 10 descendants - fan
fiction stories that are better than the
original part - if you liked it then
check out 10 descendants - fan fiction
stories that are better than the
original thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]